ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh we are very sorry it's
taken us a long time uh to get these
episodes out for you
um you know we are late we're a day late
here uh we took off last week because we
had two bears with Tom shigura if you've
not listened to that you should
um and our patreon episode will be out
later today but we were just finishing
up a little bit of a studio revamp and
uh the last few shows on this first mini
leg of a tour I wasn't out there doing a
ton of stand up I was in a movie that I
carried a little bit
um even though it was one scene it was
kind of the glue in the film
um and it monopolized a lot of my time
of three months of my time uh shooting
at what will be like a mega Blockbuster
um hopefully and I was unable to be on
the road uh the way I you kind of am and
so we kind of strung together a tour
that was all over the place but but a
lot of you guys came out and we sold out
Chicago theater and we almost sold out
the Masonic there was a few uh tickets
left in San Fran which is wow is that
bad over there you know it is not it is
not it is not a right-wing media
narrative that San Francisco is bad it
is truly bad it is mouth the gape you
like the bear from the Sochi Olympics
thank you Russia
um but it is mouth again uh oh my god
I've never seen anything like this broad
daylight
horror and uh you know
all the stores are leaving
and so I was really impressed we did
about 2 000 tickets
in a city in that condition
that's great I think that's I'm happy
with that I am happy with that
um I I think it's gonna be the next
American city to fall
remember when Detroit fell Detroit fell
that's how you knew people had given up
on the country
um Detroit didn't have a police force
they didn't it was hard to get water to
certain parts of the set like the city
fell and we went
okay San Fran is going to be the next
city
to be completely abandoned which is sad
the food is amazing we went to a Chinese
restaurant
picked it at random and we went right
after the show some of the best Chinese
food you'll ever have
um
it's an important city culturally it's
an important city
um in a lot of different respects you
know uh economically it was very
important to Northern California uh a
lot of the uh you know tech companies
originated in San Francisco
um but now it is it is as it is as bad
as it's gonna get I don't know how it
gets worse
I don't I don't know what could happen
to make it worse
um
and uh you know there's nothing to do
except go in and and then leave
immediately but it is fun if you like a
little bit of disaster tourism which I
like I think and you got to be sick
[__] to enjoy it
but if you're watching this you are part
of the fun of the next 30 Years in
America will be kind of a disaster
tourism going to the worst places there
will be many
where you have fentanyl addicts in the
street I saw a guy in San Fran he was
[__] and jabbing himself with a
needle in his leg
and you know I gotta be honest with you
listen is it sad yes but
you have to make the best of it and I do
believe that like part of the next
you know the next
phase of tourism in America will be like
it's not only going to be like let's see
the you know Yellowstone National Park
it's gonna be like let's see the city
that everybody's fleeing let's go to the
place that every and it's kind of fun
and you get into the Chinese restaurant
you're like looking outside you're like
what's going on and then you see like a
homeless person and they're like kind of
got a thing over them and they're draped
in like a cape but they're still on the
motorized chair and they just go by and
then you're like you're hitting the guy
next to you you're like look at that
look at that we're in it we're in it
it's fun it's a little fun and you have
to embrace it and I think out of that
San Francisco's next move it's like
we're a ghoulish attraction it's become
a ghoulish attraction and it's a little
fun you know because the food is great
and it's fun but you're always kind of
alert I mean why are these faggity
Americans going to escape rooms why do
they
manufacturing danger for their sad
Suburban meaningless lives go to the
cities we've ruined go to the cities
that we've destroyed with with our
politics go to the places where we've
crushed the human spirit and enjoy them
for what they are I mean isn't that
better than doing a dumb escape room or
doing something stupid these people go
to haunted houses
haunted Hera you don't need any of that
you're an adult
adults should go to these go to Flint
Michigan and the here's actually why you
can't get mad at me because I know
people are getting maybe like they're
like oh this is actually not tasteful it
is and I'll tell you why
gawking at the human
waste because it's just a waste of
potential of Life whatever you want to
say right I mean it's not I'm not into
they are human beings and I'm not
trivializing the problems what I'm
saying is gawking at them in their
moment of need actually helps them
because the tourism money they need
if you go to Flint Michigan to gawk at
the hell you're filling up the hotels
you're filling up the restaurants it's
actually good for them it's actually not
what you're thinking it's the other way
so all these people that are like well
this sounds actually pretty heartless so
you're telling me I should go with my
Suburban you know comfortably middle
class group of friends and we should go
do a night or two in a disaster area
like Sanford yes yes because the tourism
dollar helps them
and it is a little fun it's fun because
you know this is going to sound horrible
at a certain point of drug addiction and
I've been a drug addict you you really
are not a person at that point you're
not a person at that point it's really
true no one wants to talk about this but
I'll do it because we have a beautiful
set and we have the Sochi bear provided
by Russia now you're not I've been there
I've been in the depths of a drug
addiction meaning I was a uh you know
and I think maybe the worst of it was
when I was in my early 20s I was
directionless I was working in finance
and I was doing drugs all the time
snorting cocaine drinking smoking weed
taking pills I was not a human being at
that point
because I was you become the drug you
just become this thing that wants drugs
and you want to feel better and and you
exist in a binary state of being either
high or anxiety ridden trying to get
drugs those are the only two it's a
binary existence
um and those drugs pale in comparison to
fentanyl or uh crocodile or whatever the
hell is going on in San Francisco tranq
dope or whatever the new things are you
can't even keep up with them so I'm not
saying that these people at one point
weren't human beings and I'm not saying
there isn't a human being down deep in
there but at this point they may as well
be animatronic you know it's a small
world it's a small world after all at
this point they may as well be
animatronic It's a small world they're
because they're not they're making
shapes with their own bodies that no
one's ever seen before the the way they
can bend and shift and the things
they're doing the way their eyes are
driving around they're wearing this and
it's really amazing the post-apocalyptic
stuff their work they're doing big hats
and it's very black and large capes and
I like it I think it's actually good
it's very and they're on the motorized
scooter and I'm gonna send you I'm gonna
send you and I want you to bring this up
and I want you to close up on this woman
and I don't know if it's a woman and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter and
again I'm not trying because this
this helps them do you get it are you
with me on this going and gawking going
and giggling going and going oh my God
it helps them
I'm telling you and I know it it doesn't
seem like it does I am but it does it
does it does it does and I don't know
the problem so here I'm sending this to
the good producer and now I want you to
put this up on the screen for everyone
to see because I want you
to
basically let me and we're going to
close up we're doing close up on this
person here and this woman now again
this people are going to get I I already
see people going to get angry with me
but that doesn't I I can't not do what I
do here because I'm making sense now I
want you I just sent you the close-up
version too the next version is going to
be close up I'm sending now okay you can
do it yourself get in there get in on
her tight get it on her tight okay
listen
when I tell you
this is one of the better looking people
in San Francisco right now now
listen they go by and they Zip by you
and and it's fun because
by
did listen to me I know that I I know
that this isn't but it's true why are
people why are you mad at me I didn't
give them the fence at all I'm not
letting them do this to themselves I am
not letting them do this to themselves
but I like that hat she has it's sort of
that hat with the on the top with that
look at the Fit For A Minute look at the
fit because the fit is actually not bad
at all by any stretch the fit is not bad
now I hope this woman goes to heaven
soon because we have let her now you
could get it away now but you we have
let her here's the problem we have led
these cities descend into chaos we have
let people destroy their lives with
narcotics because we feel like it is
compassionate to not arrest them force
them into treatment or put them in jail
and because we've decided that all the
problems in America
and there were some of them that
certainly come from inequality we know
that we're not dumb San Francisco is one
of the highest housing you know it's
crashing now but it's one of the most
expensive places to live and we know
that people can get forced into
homelessness because they're in a real
estate market that is pricing them out
and we know that and we're not saying
but we we also have to recognize that
the homeless problem in San Francisco is
not just a function of the rising cost
of housing it is a function of of
rampant drug use that has been
normalized in every part of the city
where people that are addicted to drugs
can do them in the street can buy them
in the street can turn tricks uh you
know with their bodies and buy drugs
immediately after
it's not simply just about wealth
inequality which is a great talking
point of people there's many other
things that are going into it
um it's an issue of policing it's an
issue frankly of what you will tolerate
as a city so I am saying at this point
now absent any other options going to
San Francisco and gawking at the people
whose lives have been destroyed by the
politics of that city is actually the
most Humane thing you can do it is the
most Humane thing you can do because
otherwise you are ignoring it and you're
not spending your money there and even
if you spend your money there will it
help not really but it's better than not
spending your money there they need a
tax base they need something they need
to give someone a blanket
so the reality is I know that it seems
cruel and heartless to suggest my course
of action which is to make San Francisco
a tourism hub for people that want to
just you know they're kind of bored and
they're and they want to go there and
they kind of want to be like oh my God
but I'm telling you right now it's
actually great it's actually the right
thing to do it's the right thing to do
um because it infuses the city with
capital
and and if we're not going to solve it
if we're not going to develop better
policies
um the only thing left to do truly truly
is to to to see it as a kind of a
haunted house like a screen Park to see
it as a little bit of a scream park and
to go and eat the good food and the
great quesadilla at El Farolito or the
great and then you comment you know and
then you're just like whoa look at that
whoa look at that one oh my God and I'm
telling you it actually helps I'm
telling you right now I've been in car
accidents they suck and you know I wish
I had Morgan and Morgan because the
reality is I I was in a lot of car
accidents some of them I may have caused
bygones doesn't matter but 35 of all
fatal accidents occur between 6 p.m and
midnight okay it's it's it's crazy
people age 25 to 34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to car accidents of all age groups
you need a law firm if you're ever
injured check out Morgan and Morgan I'm
telling you it's more like using an app
than hiring a lawyer it's so easy
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as pie
eating it for cutting it and eating it
because pie is easy Morgan and Morgan is
a law firm and you know what they do
they help you because you're injured now
and you need someone to submit a claim
on your behalf and get paid submitting a
claiming Morgan Morgan is easier than
stopping yourself from singing at the
top of your lungs whenever Sweet
Caroline I don't I'm here's the point
are you injured in an accident
call Morgan and Morgan were you
rear-ended were you T-boned did someone
whack you in the McDonald's
drive-through you you've had fake
Whiplash forever right weren't you in an
accident it's not fake it's real it but
it's fake what happened someone hit you
yeah like a Brentwood mom hit me on the
same percentage and and well then and
then you've been ringing that
like have you sued her I
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
their fees free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com Champ
or dial pound law pound 529 from your
cell phone that's for the people t-h-e
p-e-o-p-l-e.com slash Tim or pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement the the cast of Boy Meets
World who by the way look as bad if not
worse than the uh uh citizens of San
Francisco the cast of Boy Meets World
which is a show that I grew up watching
uh is getting involved in the rider
strike they are it is so sad by the way
La has been great now for months because
God hates the writers apparently
um God loves Executives who knew
God grace since
done on their jobs it has been nothing
but gray and overcast now the writers uh
are negotiating for a better deal which
again we are supporting the writers well
I support them you know but I've said
many times on the show literally my best
friends are all the streamer CEO
Executives so it's like weird
I I occupy this like weird middle space
that being said
this is a very sad thing here's what
happens this is what happens
let's just be very clear about what this
is these people are done they're done in
the business they're done
at one point they had it all they were
on a hot show
people cared they had stuff going on at
this point they are done in this
business and their lives are horrible
they are a few steps away from that
woman in the wheelchair with the hat
okay this is not a nice place when they
throw you out it throw they throw you
out you're done these people are done
now however they're getting they're
they're back in because of the wga
strike and it's very sad they do this
bit it's not a bit it's very sad that
doesn't really land no one knows who
they are
they show up to this thing they're
trying to make it like look at us to
cast a Boy Meets World is here now let's
get serious can you imagine the
executives being like hold on
Boy Meets World is it and by the way
it's not even Fred Sapp right the star's
not even there
the star Fred Savage is not even there
but I just imagine like Ted sarandos and
Netflix just you know outside the window
he's looking down he's up on his uh
Penthouse corner office he's like [__]
so they have the the cast of Boy Meets
World huh yeah all right
let's go down let's address them and let
they all go down to the picket line and
but but they do this really sad bit
where the older brother on Boy Meets
World's like we were on a show in the
60s they're trying to do this bit cause
it was the 90s and everything and like
but close up on them let's play this and
I want you to look at the pain in their
faces
hell and I'm Ryder Strong I'm Trina
McGee and I'm Wilfredo and we were all
on the show in the 1960s called Boy
Meets World
yeah
thank you very much the 60s were an
important time for me anyway whenever we
needed Clarity in our lives or just some
sort of wisdom we all went to one very
specific person and I think it's
necessary to summon him now if you don't
mind oh wait wait will I thought you
didn't do the call anymore I don't but I
think I'm gonna make an exception all
right here we go everybody ready yeah
yeah
hey
guys
[Music]
hi I'm Bill Daniels known by many as Mr
Feeney
I have always held riders in the highest
regard I mean this is I'd rather watch
the Ukraine Warp
believe in yourselves
dream try do good okay all right we
can't yeah
all right thank you this was very tough
to watch this is very sad
the cast of Boy Meets World by the way I
mean blaggard
sad I mean It's just tough I would I
would never show I would never show up
if I was
I would never I would just oof would I
would I leave and never come back would
I leave and never come back you know
but that's why we we can't make cities
like Austin these like up and coming
Hotsy because that was like the
retirement that's where these people
should go after they were like that was
the point that's where you go that's
where you go like after you know you did
Boy Meets World and it didn't work out
and you know but it was just sad to
watch them and they're doing this chant
you know we all know Mr Feeney was a
principal on Boy Meets World but no one
really gives a [__] no one cares anymore
about anything and it's just very sad to
see them do that bit and it's foodie
what do you think happened after that
moment you think Ryder's strong like
just gotten like an old car and lit a
cigarette and I just stared at the Gloom
you know he was the hot guy uh Corey's
friend Sean right yeah you imagine that
I mean the Topanga was the one with the
big tits what do you think happens after
they just get in a you know right you
think they carpooled do you think
there's multiple cars owned in that
group what do you think do you think
there's like a one do you think they do
an Uber pool that Ryder Strong is
driving he goes all right he turns to
her he goes he turns her and goes by the
way can you request it because I
actually have to
yeah I mean it's it's tough it's tough
to watch because obviously some of these
writers are cut you know they're being
they're they're coming back from the
dead
some of these people it's like Night of
the Living Dead on these picket lines
out here people that haven't worked in
Forever people are like oh my god what
happened to you and they're like ah you
know they cut let's bust them in from
San Fran some of those people were
writers too
um but again we hope this ends soon and
we wish them well I mean that's that's
all we can do here it's all we could do
um that's another thing if you if San
Fran is too much disaster tourism drive
by the wga picket lines in Hollywood and
you will see a lot of people whose lives
are in disarray their lives are in
disarray
um
well and by the way just to make a quick
uh state in the Ukraine
counter-offensive is on underway we
don't know how they're doing it's mixed
reactions we can't get anything uh real
in the press the New York Times however
is now starting to acknowledge that like
some of the Nazi symbols on the front
line of the Ukraine uh are a bit
confusing Nazi symbols on Ukraine's
front lines highlights thorny issues of
History there's nothing better than the
word thorny
uh troops use of patches bearing Nazi
emblems risks fueling Russian propaganda
so now again this is hilarious I want
you to read this headline like you're an
adult
troops use of patches bearing Nazi
emblems risks fueling Russian propaganda
uh what about it risks fueling the
reality that they like Nazis and or are
Nazis
which again you can say
that we have a strategic interest in
working with them
if you want I don't know that that's the
case I've argued you know quite
persuasively on multiple platforms
um that it we don't that our strategic
interest is actually in trying to
de-escalate this conflict
but it's hilarious this is the paper of
record the New York Times are coming out
and they're going well because remember
when this started everybody was pinning
metals on these guys and you know they
were showing up at gallus or whatever
and they were going these are the heroes
and these and when you know all this
stuff and now and then a lot of people
were like wait a minute but Ukraine for
years in addition to being one of the
most corrupt countries in Europe was a
hot bed a Bastion if you will of white
supremacy of of literal Nazism of Youth
Nazi movements and I'm not saying we
don't we've got a few in this country
the little Nazis running around here as
well right but like you know they had
like Charlottesville 2.0 I mean you know
again I'm not saying that we don't have
those issues but you know for years and
years everyone in the media called
everyone that had a differing opinion on
anything and Nazi that was a pejardative
thrown at a lot of people you're not and
there were real Nazis there are
legitimately
real you know people in America that
genuinely are down that road you know
and that's obviously you know worth
pointing out but when you broad brush
everybody say Nazi Nazi Nazi it cut
likes calling everyone a racist or what
they're doing uh right now on Twitter
everyone's groomer everyone's a
pedophile we love just one word and then
like the people that are really like if
you were an actual Pentagon though
you're probably like huh okay man
they're can't they're they got a big net
here they'll never get me
um but now the New York Times is finally
starting to admit
because it's got to be awkward for them
right because like they're over there
trying to portray this as a one thing
this narrative is something
an image of a Ukrainian Soldier wearing
a patch containing the Toten Cove symbol
an example of Nazi iconography that was
posted on the Twitter account of
Ukraine's defense Ministry then deleted
he
but you have to admit that they are not
I mean it's like kind of hilarious
they're like literally they've got the
patches
they're they're sieg hiling they're
doing all this stuff and then like the
New York Times is like well
these patches might Aid in Russian
propaganda I'm like maybe these patches
are going to make Americans think we
shouldn't be dumping hundreds of
billions of dollars into this war that
is so clear-cut
I guess if you are six like if you were
a child like many of the Hollywood
celebrities that comment on this war are
um then it's easily explained if you
know anything about world history like
the slightest bit like anything like uh
if you like watched half of a
documentary once before you lost Wi-Fi
in a plane you would know that it's
actually thorny as the New York Times
would say it's a little thorny okay when
the United States and NATO acts as a
[__] imperialist aggressor all over
the world and is encircling Russia a
country that's deeply paranoid about
being invaded rightly or wrongly they
are okay and if you look at their
history it you can you can pretty much
see why okay they've been invaded
multiple times now when a country like
that sees the United States encroaching
into their area okay when they see what
happened in the Ukraine when Ukraine is
going and almost really ethnically
cleansing russian-speaking people
they're banning political party parties
they're banning the Russian Orthodox
Church okay the Ukraine sending these
paramilitary troops into those regions
to per with the help of the CIA to purge
any Russian uh National or or Russian
loyalist or Russian speaker whatever it
is when all of that's happening and
Russia decides that they are going to go
and now again Putin's I don't think he's
uh I mean you know this obviously I mean
I I do have this which I do I do value
this
but listen we we you know Putin is not
Bernie Sanders we're not trying to make
that argument here that Putin is Bernie
Sanders what we are saying is this is a
deeply complex issue and a lot of it
might have to do with the fact that you
know we have been encroaching and
pushing into that Sphere for a long time
and you know when I had the two uh young
guys on the show The Biden guys who were
talking the the Biden boys
um who I still talk to I do like a lot
um we're not they're not I mean they're
crazy but I liked I love them but
they're nuts but
you know I was trying to explain to them
like you know the world is not a film
you know what I mean like it's not a
video game it's not a film I think you
know the the problem with the way that
we process advances we we're totally
ignorant of history in America ignorant
of it like anything before season three
of selling Sunset we don't know we are
ignorant of History we don't we're not
taught world history in America we're
not taught world history we don't know
we have no idea we're constantly arguing
about the American history that we
should be taught here you know
um you know at what you know at what
point should kindergartners be shown 12
Years a Slave or whatever the arguments
that are happening all the time are now
you know or or how many genders are in
uh music class but outside of that
outside of these things there's actually
an entire world out there that has its
own history that we could uh look at
slightly and if you had a any
understanding of that at all from a
Global Perspective you would know that
this concept is not what you are being
told by the lying people uh at the New
York Times I hate to say it it's just
not it's not it's absolutely not okay
and that doesn't mean that Putin is
Bernie Sanders and it doesn't mean what
it means is that if you're an adult
and and the New York Times has to go
we're sorry about the Nazi patches being
worn by the guys we are funding to the
tune of a trillion dollars we're sorry
about that because it would spread
Russian propaganda if you look at their
clothes
the newspaper of record the fact that
they have to do this the fact that
they're even taught it means there's
more [__] coming down the pike I'm
telling you I've been in a game a while
if they have to do this it means that
there's more stuff coming down the pike
they're getting out in front of it
they're trying to get ahead of it
because there's more stuff coming if
they're if they're writing an article
about fashion in the middle of a counter
offensive it means that there's more
coming yo I'm telling you the
this war is going to unwind
go much quicker than Iraq much quicker
than Afghanistan now in real time you're
seeing it with the vaccine you're seeing
it with that they're like everybody take
them out today it'll be fine everybody's
fine and then you get covered nine times
after you've taken the vaccine and none
of these people have the decency to just
shut up I bet they're still promoting it
they're still pumping it I was a
subprime mortgage guy after a good scam
leave quietly you know we didn't knock
on people's doors a year after we sold
them a mortgage we go how's it going I'm
the guy you know we you get it
stick and move Hustler move
move but you're gonna you're gonna see
this
you're going to it's we're already
started like zelinski's going to get
because the American people have kind of
already had enough there's a little bit
of fatigue here so the government's
going to throw zielinsky away the way
they throw everyone away they throw
everyone away when they're no longer
useful remember that chick Christine
blasey Ford who went out and accused uh
the Kavanaugh the Supreme Court guy and
then she was like the Talk of the Town
for two weeks then it was like you're
out they're gonna throw Megan in hat
when Megan and Harry first moved here
and we could hit the royal family and
say they're racist and now we're sick of
them and they're out he's out soon
zielinski's on his 14th minute right now
and that's where they're starting to run
articles like this little by little
they're preparing people for the total
about face where we go yeah we love that
I don't know it'll be an ultimate
gaslighting it'll be like yeah we don't
yeah that was there were Nazis there
they were like Nazi we didn't know like
oh my God like it's going to be a total
gas line thing they're going to like
they're doing with the vet you know when
Trudeau goes like I never told no no one
required you to take the vaccine
nobody's who is requiring you to take
the vacation you needed to get into a
deli they're they're saying so this will
be a total gaslighting too and and if
you're actually somewhat aware you can
start to see these little articles
little seeds that they're planting like
well you know and they are wearing Nazi
vests that's weird that's odd because
we've realized we can't we got to
prepare for China now because that's the
real fight China it's not this crap
everybody right now is getting ready for
the summer they're getting ready to hook
up and you've got to make sure your body
your man area is good manscaped we've
been telling you about manscape forever
the performance package 4.0 inside this
package you'll find their lawnmower
trimmer the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer the crop preserver bull
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
all your goodies the lawnmower 4.0 you
can call yourself
uh you call yourself an American without
a lawnmower
I'll tell you this manscape works it's
the best on the market there's a few
things on the market there's the wall
trimmer which socks and a relical body
groom's not great this is a thing we all
get them for free everybody uses them
everybody likes the manscape trimmer
truly if you need one you can go the
promo code is Tim D right great way to
support the show great way to get a good
product and you save money right you're
gonna get 20 off with free shipping with
our discount code also they're doing now
nose and ear it used to just be dick and
balls now their nose and ear everywhere
hair is sprouting you can address it
with manscape it's very important I'm
telling you and for the Die Hard
Patriots who wants to Rocket Dirty Stash
of goatee by the pool look no further
than the manscape's brand new beard
hedger Pro kit if you also are really
rocking the facial hair for the summer
take your freedom Balls to the next
level by going to manscape.com get 20
off with free uh free shipping promo
code Tim D 20 off free shipping promo
code Tim D if you're thinking about
taking an environmentally sound vacation
because that's most people right now
most people in America are concerned
with their carbon footprint when they
travel is that not true is that not true
is that isn't that why we love cruises
so much because it's an efficient way to
get 3 000 morbidly obese people out into
the middle of the ocean is that not why
we're doing it
but they're at CBS News by the way now
imagine running this story I mean this
is kind of hilarious so CBS News in the
midst of what's going on where we have
one of our presidents is indicted uh one
of our presidents Donald Trump our
ex-president was indicted uh Joe Biden
is going to be uh you know uh you know
perhaps dealing with some stuff about
the purisma the Energy company in the
where Ukraine that's coming out that he
had deals with with him and his son
um we have this real crisis of uh
confidence in our political systems with
our justice department may be acting
politically uh we have issues all over
the place and CBS has decided that right
now the most important thing to focus on
is uh how much methane gas is being used
on your trip uh in the summer now most a
lot of Americans cannot afford to go on
a trip now of course CBS doesn't cover
that CBS doesn't cover that they don't
cover the fact that there's people that
are lining up at Food Bank because they
can't eat uh their children are going to
bed hungry they can't find work they're
living in areas of the country that
we've given up on Rural America we don't
give a [__] Republican Democrat whoever
nobody gives a [__] about any of these
so they're not talking to those people
but they are talking to people I guess
that are going to take a vacation not
only are they going to take a vacation
but they have the luxury of thinking
about how to do it in an environmentally
sound way
CBS News let's watch this right and by
the way when you watch this it is the
most insane segment I have seen in a
very long time from the media and that
tells you something let's watch the good
people at CBS News the Weekender
this summer some people are looking for
ways to take a vacation while also
cutting down on their greenhouse gas
emissions
Market is expected to exceed at 331
billion dollars by 2027 according to new
research data ecotourism can have an
impact on where some people choose to
visit and how they get there let's bring
in tree mint a features editor for
discover magazine tree let's talk about
some destinations where folks can
actually give back to the planet I love
this by the way I love CBS News to go
they go
is there a way we can do because we're
trying to push this ecotourism thing is
there a way we could do it with a trans
person named tree
is there a way we can do this segment
with a trans person named tree
they're like we have a trans person
named Sarah they go no no we'd like to
try and and no no shade to tree but it's
just very funny and again let's watch
some of this because it is just very
funny this idea that like ecotourism
which by the way is the most loosely
defined thing ever it's just gonna be
people go rich people going to like nice
places and they're gonna go they're just
it's eco-tourism they want to lower
their carbon footprint it's glamping and
it's like okay it's not they're not
primarily concerned with their carbon
footprint they want to take Instagram
photos in Montana in a tent but all
right let's see what tree has to say
yeah absolutely so you know this whole
this whole thing is a trend across the
country I think that tourism is an
amazing place where it fits in you know
one of the first places
trees are real Mensch state parks and
County parks that have a wealth of
opportunities for amazing destinations
to immerse yourself in but also the
money you're spending there the
activities you're doing are typically
directly going back and actually
sustaining that environment right so go
scuba diving that's under you know list
of uh guidelines and understanding that
experts and scientists have of watching
what's happening in these ecosystems and
making sure they're balanced and healthy
for everybody that visits as well as all
the creatures and plants that live there
well it's great to know that you can
actually do it locally and not spend a
lot of money to travel but let's say you
do decide to travel what are some of the
activities that you can look forward to
sure I mean the list is pretty much
endless you can really cater your
interests to local and very eco-friendly
destinations I mean one example would be
the ocean in general this is the news by
the way this is the news in the United
States of America they're telling you
you can go to the ocean
this is the news this is CBS News in the
United States of America
CBS News has a a segment with someone
named tree who is sitting in their room
on Zoom telling you that there's
something I don't know if you've heard
of it called the ocean that you can go
to what do they think Americans do on
vacations
that are so ecologically unfriendly that
they don't do every day of their lives
and they're using stock photo they're
using stock photo of a a white woman
here I don't know running her hand on
sugar cane while she walks down like
these stock photos are very interesting
I don't understand what that's supposed
to be but this whole idea of Eco vacate
like what is so they're saying you you
don't have to fly
I guess you don't have to go to theme
parks because they're not eco-friendly
you could go to the ocean okay that's
the bit that's the segment that they're
doing is that an example of an Eco keep
going with this because I'm curious It's
like what are these eco-friendly but
aren't most summer destinations like
lakes and oceans isn't most of it
eco-tourism isn't that where everyone
goes in the [__] summer what the hell
is going on at CBS shout out to
Catherine Harris though she's been doing
this a long time Catherine Herridge has
been at every network with that Frozen
face full of wrestling like
keep going
um so you know one thing we like to plug
folks into are things like um their
citizen science opportunities all across
the country the great resource for that
is sizestarter.org where essentially
like you want to go to the ocean you
want to see dolphins they're actually
scientists out there who need the help
of everyday citizens who are
experiencing the ocean and maybe wanna
no they don't rain for dolphins maybe
they don't need the help of American
citizens go out into the ocean and
there's a network of organizations where
he'll eat look it's pauses for a minute
is this they're literally telling people
did scientists need the help of people
to hatch Turtles
and keep monitor Dolphins what are they
doing with all this money I have to now
work as a scientist on my I have a job I
have a [__] job I have to go and
hatch Turtles
first of all Americans are going to eat
the things they find they're all going
into a pot
so this is just the craziest thing ever
you can be a scientist scientists need
your help well they didn't need your
help about the vaccine
they didn't need your help even if you
asked a question like how about you
leave it to the experts but now we're
supposed to [__] finger [__]
offense and hatch Turtles
let's finish this up with trees it's
happening unfold while you're having an
amazing experience and Paradise often
what are some of the destinations and
activities you should avoid if you're
trying to protect them this is going to
be good
sure yeah so you know it's really going
to depend on what environment you are in
would it be great if he goes emphasizes
having heterosexual sex
[Laughter]
um having had or she I don't know what
trees identifying as having heterosexual
or they this thing that uh having
heterosexual sex and having children and
going to church those are the things
that I think are they leave the biggest
carbon footprint
um uh having children in a heterosexual
Bond of marriage and going to church
that christenings
that would just be treat that's what I
research facilities they're going to
have a list of guidelines things as
simple as stay on the trail which might
sound kind of like simple and something
that maybe we our curiosity gets the
best of us and we want to wander off um
potatoes guidelines at a certain place
are actually really Dynamic to protect
the health of the ecosystem that are
there so following the rules and
guidelines that are there now CBS is
using
um a bunch of black people who seem lost
there's a bunch of Africans CBS is now
using stock footage of a bunch of
Africans whose tour bus has overturned
and they're walking around in the bush
in the jungle trying to figure out
I mean can CBS not who is doing the
stock footage over there at CBS this is
crazy
from activities that you're going to do
when you really hone in on operations
and things that are run by locals who
live in the community work there it's
most likely that the money that they're
receiving is really going to be put back
into the health and the long-term
sustainability of that place for their
Wellness as well as all the things that
live there
um so it's really good to just kind of
follow those those tips there's
something called disaster tourism what
does that look like yes yes
yes yes different different kind of
applications you know where where people
will kind of flood into an area you know
in response to sort of a devastating
event or something that happens there to
try and you know help and offer support
and things and that will definitely um
there's situations and circumstances
where that's called before but um since
it all usually to plug into operations
like the Red Cross operations like no no
they traffic kids what's best is to go
to San Francisco and what because they
have crazy hats like kind of the Western
League Zorro had almost and they're in
the jazzies in the run fence uh no thank
you tree's wrong they're all wrong as
always usual you only have to listen to
me thank you that's the reality you just
do disaster tourism actually is tree was
right you do show up you do try to help
um and the response to an event and it's
a collapse of San Francisco disaster
tourism let's talk about the CEO of
Dippin Dots because you strangle his
girlfriend to death is it to death or
did he just strangle her
this is the way I I just strangled her
yeah yeah
yeah why is that even news
I think because Dippin Dots is like a
significant company is it a significant
company is Dippin Dots Dipping Dots for
all of you I used to do a great ice
cream bit that's still on YouTube better
versions are live comedy's always better
live but it's actually a good version on
YouTube uh and then Dippin Dots is the
ice cream brand that's like gravel it's
they freeze ice cream in a little
pellets that look like uh rabbit [__] or
something and you eat them and they have
different flavors get up Dippin Dots so
people could just see what it is you
know they're usually at rest stops
they're these tiny Frozen nitrogen
Frozen balls of flavors that kind of
approximate The Taste it's like it's
like I don't know I'd rather astronaut
ice cream like from the planetarium like
that that bar of dry ice cream you'd get
at the planetarium that was actually
kind of cooler Dippin Dots for me has
always been strange although we did have
them when we were in uh Wawa remember
that we were in Wawa we stole them I
think yeah yeah now you don't pay for
these never pay for dippers never ever
pay for dip and die he's strangling his
chick so now what happened to this man
how by the way I don't even know how
dipadas was founded how was it founded
uh it sounds like it was like a domestic
thing I think yeah well we know it was a
domestic thing oh no that's he was
arrested on complaints of public
intoxication domestic violence by
strangulation walking outside naked in a
drunken rage let's see what this
happened to him
the CEO of Dippin Dots was reportedly
arrested Tuesday for allegedly attacking
his girlfriend and storming outside
their Oklahoma home completely naked in
a drunken fueled rage
Scott Fisher she probably insulted the
ice cream she was probably like it's got
the socks it's always sucked Scott had
served at rest stops shut up
Scott Fisher was a history of abuse was
booked on complaints of blah blah blah
he's 43. he attacked a woman hours after
she confronted him about his alcohol
abuse which reportedly escalated over
the past several weeks
he's probably very invested in these
Ukraine counter-offensive it's a lot of
Americans are having problems now the
girlfriend whose identity was not
revealed in the documents had reportedly
returned from work to her Oklahoma City
home and found the former ice cream man
intoxicated the former ice cream man was
drunk they verbally fought
until uh
is it magnate yeah it's like the share
of constable kind of deal yeah until the
yeah I I don't know what happened here
he choked her you know I mean he choked
her by the way this is horrible too the
gunman who killed his three children
right did you hear about this yeah
yeah this is crazy uh gunman kills six
and horrific murder suicide including
three kids as its revealed wife feared
he would get drunk and shoot me the the
mental health problems in this country
are so bad now
that I don't think it's
I I don't think it's
hyperbole to suggest
that there are so many people that
you're looking at that are on the brink
of doing something crazy or having a
full-on mental breakdown
um that you just have to tread carefully
tread lightly out there
you know and obviously I'm not blaming
anyone this was a horrible thing that
happened
but there's a lot of people out there
that are really they have untreated
mental illness it's like psychosis and
this guy Tennessee man went on a violent
Rampage murdering his estranged wife her
daughter and three kids after she worn
to court he had 50 or 60 guns and was
afraid he would get drunk and shoot me
officials with the I mean listen let's
be honest I I'm pro-gun to to a degree
50 or 60 guns might be an indication
there's something going on it might not
be I mean people are going to attack me
now in the comments for that which I
don't care 50 or 60.
might be an indicate I mean how many
well people have 60 rifles
you know I understand you're preparing
for the apocalypse but do you need 60
seems like a lot that seems like a lot
[__] because you know you're gonna fight
the government with them I know but the
government has drones but whatever it
doesn't matter even if you you know
what's fine I understand that the spirit
of it right
I understand that 60 seems like a bit
much
well it's not your business
the guy shot his kids you know
Sheriff Bo Burnett confirmed Barnett had
worked in the Machine Tool industry it
was the one who shot and killed his wife
for Gina I mean this is so sad there's
nothing funny about this but
I I will say and keep going here I mean
she warned the court and she warned that
this could happen
um
he threatened to shoot her he verbally
abused her
and he killed his
children
she worked at the Seymour handle Factory
she was making handles and where did he
work again
do we know
I believe he was a
I don't know how I'd have to see the
local TV station I think he was just
I mean so I mean this is really crazy
he's one of I mean it's like it's this
is like mind-blowing stuff he also might
not have had a job either I mean there's
that too
yeah and I mean so she works at a handle
Factory
he worked in a machine tool Factory I
think
and then he shot everybody and killed
them
imagine Rogers and Hammerstein trying to
write a musical about this era of
America
you know what I mean where everybody's
just working in factories and killing
each other everybody's executing their
own families that seems like a tough
thing to get you know remember the
Rogers and Hammer seat musicals like
Oklahoma oh Oklahoma where the wind
comes sweeping down the plane and he
killed his kids you know like it's It's
just tough to to imagine America in this
state uh the writing great fun musicals
about it because there used to be great
musicals about the things that were
going on people falling in and out of
love people having these fun little
rivalries but now it just seems to have
gotten so dark so hopeless in many cases
that it's very tough to imagine any type
of fun musical being written about the
lives that people are living now you
know Oklahoma the great musical Oklahoma
now that guy who's living in Oklahoma
founded Dippin Dots and he's strangling
his wife
and I'm not saying that wasn't happening
then but it does seem to be we do seem
to be confronted with it more now for
sure everybody's using expressvpn it's
very important everybody's trying to get
your data your information governments
hackers people that are harvesting and
selling your data data is more expensive
than oil now expressvpn doesn't log your
activity online lots of it's uh
you know lots of cheap and free vpns
make money by selling your data to
advertisers expressvpn does not do this
they even developed a technology trusted
server that makes their VPN service
incapable of storing any data at all
speed expressvpn uses lightweight a new
VPN protocol the engineered to make user
speeds faster than ever I've tried many
vpns in the past and sometimes it can
slow my connection but not expressvpn
it's blazing fast and it lets me stream
videos in HD quality with zero buffering
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use you don't need any technical skills
to get to set up just fire up the app
and tap one button to connect that's it
even your grandparents could do it and
it's not just me saying this Business
Insider The Verge and many other Tech
journals ready expressvpn the number one
VPN in the world so to protect yourself
with the VPN that I use and trust and my
whole team uses and Trust use my link
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon today and get
an extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expressvpn.com
dot com slash Tim Dillon to learn more I
love box of awesome it's a great thing
to give to people okay you get one every
month bespoke post this is how it works
you take a quiz
the quiz could be about what you're into
or about what the person you're giving
the box to is into
they're going to get a box once a month
at their door with really cool stuff in
it 90 of everything that comes in your
box of awesome is from a small up and
coming brand it could be stuff for the
Outdoorsman the mixologist the bartender
the foodie you know the recreational uh
camper whatever
and more
it's really interesting to see these
these products they put in a box and
once every month you go oh my God I
forgot I was getting this and here it is
and it's great and I love it and
everybody loves me well I took a quiz
and
they sent me a box
and in that box
it was amazing how well they knew me
how well they knew me
in that box because you know it was in
that box
cool stuff
but get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code Tim Dillon to check out
that's box of awesome this is a really
cool thing especially you got College
age kids or whatever just get it for
them positive awesome.com good timed
over 20 off your first box get them this
so they're not yelling about Biden
listen we the the studio looks good we
like it there's gonna be more
advancements made and things happening
we you know there's gonna we do like it
um we're all over the place we're gonna
put one in New York too we're gonna put
one on the east coast it looks very
similar to this except the New York
backdrop
so that when we're over there you know
we're doing shows over there we could be
there we got to be mobile we gotta we
gotta you know La is is uh you know
we're looking at a situation where it's
rapidly deteriorating and I don't know
how long I have left here I think that
there's possible there's a potential
that I'm I I will leave again I left
once and I will leave maybe again I
don't know but as of right now we're
we're we're we're we're on the road
we're in the mix
and we want to have an East Coast thing
so that when we're on the East Coast I
spent a lot of time on the East Coast we
can touch
um we can touch down there and do the
show there as well we do appreciate
everybody's patience we know wrapping up
these shows has been a little difficult
San Francisco the Masonic and the
Chicago Theater are two of my favorite
venues in the world I love those two
cities I love the audiences there they
all came out we saw that the Chicago
Theater very close to the Masonic you
know and again it was to me everyone you
know that comes out to those shows of
great appreciation for and the shows
themselves were amazing I don't do a ton
of marketing you know a lot of other
people are much better and more Adept at
marketing than I am in terms of like
showing you everything I don't
necessarily subscribe to that and that
doesn't mean that I don't see the value
in it or I don't recognize the talent in
it it's a great show if you know and
Word of Mouth should matter and that
matters and we sell a lot of tickets
because that [__] does matter and I talk
to a lot of you guys every week so it's
um it's not like you know I hate the
feeling of like even that dumb picture
you take after the show when you do a
great show and then you're like and now
come on and you take that photo in front
of you it just to me I've never liked
doing that stuff
um but I know that I have to do it it's
more and more becoming part of this but
you know I've been able to kind of carve
up the path that I have and do it the
way I want to do it where it's just like
it's like it's kind of a Lo-Fi light
touch out there and hopefully the stuff
we put out is funny and people enjoy it
but
um we are going to be back uh from the
studio now because we are off the roads
we'll be back here every week and if you
guys are into it and you want to
subscribe to the channel or get because
you know Rumble is coming up
I mean who just signed a hundred million
dollar contact uh tract on Twitch oh the
streamers the streamer just signed but
not on Twitch the other one kick right
yeah yeah 100 million two-year contract
on kick
streamer things are changing
you know and uh streamer qxc qxc he
looks like a Sasha Baron Cohen character
I don't know what's going on anymore and
it doesn't matter
but qxc xqc leaves twitch agrees to
two-year 100 million dollar contract
with Kik
so that's what I'm saying there there
are other places you know we might start
uploading the show to Twitter
we're thinking about it in addition to
YouTube we don't know we might start
uploading the show to rumble we don't
know right now but we're experimenting
with all kinds of things but we don't
know the direction that things are going
to go in the media space but things do
seem to be heading to an interesting
place where there are more eyeballs now
across many different platforms and that
might be the best way to do it
we don't know
we wish the Ukraine well
they're counter-offensive we hope
everything comes to a conclusion we hope
that everything over there comes to a
peaceful conclusion I feel horrible for
the Ukrainian people
that are being displaced that are being
killed we all feel that way this is not
a celebration of war in fact it's the
very opposite of that it is the
recognition that one needs a
de-escalation and when you have wars
they usually end with some type of
compromise there's usually a treaty I
don't know if that'll work in this
situation I don't know I'm not a
geopolitical expert I do know that when
the New York Times starts running things
like well you know
ugh the guys were supporting War Nazi
shirts again yeah
it means that there's a little sea
change here this little wind there's a
feather and Forrest Gump that you see
you know because that's kind of
everybody's looking at the feather and
that's it's starting we're starting to
doubt the amount of of resources that
we've put into this and we're starting
to doubt uh potentially uh the
um end game I don't know if we we have
the end game here I think that we're
finally starting to look at it and go oh
well uh uh John meersheimer who's done
the best work on this
he's in my opinion he's one of the guys
to listen to
believes early on in the war that the
Ukraine at the upper hand of Russia has
it now and he doesn't believe the
Ukraine is going to win John muirshimer
again does great work on this issue
he comes at it from a very
non-ideological
non-emotional Cold Sober few which
doesn't exist in America anymore by the
way there's no non-ideal everything is
in emotional roller coaster from
emotionally unstable people named tree
um and I'm not and I don't even know
tree I'm just saying like this is where
we're at now in the country that the
people that are talking about issues of
grave importance are themselves
completely
um mentally destroyed
and they're the ones opining on issues
of great importance you know or vice
president can you get up Kamal again we
want to do this once a week where we
play a Kamala clip get up the Kamala
clip Glenn Greenwald shared this on
Twitter the other day
um and he literally said he goes uh Tim
Dylan was the first person to say that
Kamala has now crossed into genuinely
entertaining
genuinely entertaining we love her I
can't get enough of her and what's funny
about uh the the clip that Glenn had is
of course it's just Kamala being Kamala
which is you know someone who is just
you know sort of completely incapable of
actually speaking I I've never seen
anything like it she's completely
incapable of
speaking in any rational way for any
period of time she you know lapses into
these weird like colloquialisms and
stuff like that here it is Kamala here's
your vice president folks
have a seat please have a seat
she's manic now folks pause it for me
um
she's unwell you know I this is just if
someone walked into my house exhibiting
this kind of behavior I would very be
very scared for them truly if somebody
walked into like
I would go hey are you okay something
going on
this is not the Cadence of someone who's
well this is not this is not the Cadence
of someone who's love
let me guess what this Cadence is this
is the Cadence of
you know Biden's in office now Biden is
a genuine corpse she knows kind of maybe
how bad it is she can't really say it
she knows that her political career
which again was never gonna happen
because she was hated in the primaries
because she was a cop
and she was sending truancy police after
like the parents of kids who ditch
school trying to get everybody locked up
she was elevated to this position
because of identity politics and now
she's just kind of there and the guy
she's kind of hitched her wig into is
maybe about to go down for being uh you
know in bed with some shady companies in
the Ukraine she doesn't know
but she seems to be losing her mind
in front of people and I predicted this
months ago I said after Kanye
I'm like you're gonna have these really
big meltdowns public meltdowns you're
gonna see this for the first time you're
actually going to see people losing
their mind in front of you in a way that
you've never seen before let's take a
look this is the vice president of the
United States
she's nuts and to my Divine mind family
is she High
good evening everyone
something something's off with her
something's off
something's off I don't know
target has pulled my I'm gay for
Vladimir Putin Pride shirt
again
this is a capitulation to the Mob
of course people are people that are mad
about the flag it's stupid at this point
that people get that angry and that
invested in the fact that they have a
pride flag up I think it's one of these
culture War things that has been ginned
up to a degree but it also reflects the
reality of like this insane kind of
gender stuff that's going on with kids
in schools and
um so
what we're seeing now is like this crazy
backlash which anyone again it's
predictable right anybody that's looking
at all this stuff goes oh yes you're
going to get a crazy backlash you know
people were fine with gay marriage
people were kind of okay with it now
everyone wasn't they're evangelicals
there are people that want to live in a
Christian theocracy but a lot of the
public was fine with this stuff they
were cool with it and then again it just
became like but we're gonna tell your
four-year-old that they could be a boy
or a girl in kindergarten that's when
people checked out that's when people
checked out and I understand that that's
when people start going hey man we don't
need the [__] music teacher
diagnosing my child uh as a as somebody
that is gender dysphoria and we don't
want them going and getting hormones and
permanently altering their body when you
know they may regret this decision and
and that's really why you see a lot of
this backlash right now which is a
little crazy it's like dialed up to an
11 where it's like insane we're like the
Washington Times is running articles
where it's like gay people are killing
Christianity I mean but again it's like
those people are always going to be
crazy they're always going to be there
you cannot feed them you're not supposed
to feed them with this stuff where it's
like
[Music]
um
you know people need autonomy to raise
their kids how they want to raise their
kids it's just the way it is you may not
agree with it you may not like it it
doesn't matter it's just the way that
they feel
they have culture they have values they
have this
the culture of America you know at any
given point may not be the culture in a
middle eastern household or an
Evangelical Christian household and then
the kids who live in those households
are gonna have to figure it out
it's not the government's job to be
people's parents
it's not the gut you know if people are
going to be trans they'll be trans
people are going to be gay they're going
to be gay I didn't need anyone to tell
me to be gay
um you know I don't you shouldn't be
persecuted for being gay or trans
clearly but you don't need when you're
five
you don't need people necessarily
steering you in a Direction
you should just be able to be a kid and
kind of be left alone and there's too
much about the gender ideology stuff
going on right now that it like has to
be introduced to kids at this young age
and no one knows why people that are my
age gay people that are my age none of
us understand really the most of us do
not understand
why we're telling seven-year-olds that
they have the agency to physically
change their bodies and pick a gender at
this point they should dress the way
they want they can live the way they
want if they have a severe case of
gender dysphoria and they're happy
living as a as the other gender I have
no issue with that at all my issue is
when pharmaceutical companies when uh
people make medical changes to
themselves they've said it a million
times but that's why you see the
backlash now
which is a bit insane uh from people
that are they're acting like everybody's
trying to [__] their kids which it's not
everyone's not trying to [__] your kids
but there are bad ideas
you know being introduced I don't mean
transgender isn't necessarily as the bad
idea I mean the bad idea of children
knowing exactly who they are at seven or
nine
and being able to act on that having the
agency on autonomy to act on that that
to me is not a good idea a lot of those
children become gay or lesbian without
medical intervention a lot of their
feelings of isolation or weirdness or
depression or whatever end up being
corrected through puberty this is not
you know this is a reality but we're
afraid to
have these discussions because there's
so many people that don't want to be
called transphobic or whatever
homophobic and then there's the people
that really don't care on the other side
that'll like burn them into stake who
want to make America you know Saudi
Arabia with more pork but neither one of
those is the solution the solution is
actually
um a a country that as Alex Jones who I
think by the way
is becoming one of the most reasonable
people in America sorry
it's 2023 and he is
his idea of like when you were 18 you're
an adult you should be able to do what
you want within reason if it doesn't
hurt anybody else is a pretty [__]
good standard
and listen if you have severe gender
dysphoria and you're 16 or 17 you meet
with a doctor I don't think these things
should be banned
but how young
these ideas are being introduced to
people and this idea that they can
and should take me and we almost feel a
little weird about the parents too the
mom who's like I'm trans and my kids are
trans I'm non-binary and my kids are
non-binary and you go what are the
chances of that
what are the chances of that that seems
uh interesting
I come from a long line of non-binary
it's like really so there is a little
something that's inherently
uncomfortable with this gender Theory
stuff where the mom is going well the
kid is also Tran and you're going are
they or is this something that you
introduced to them
in an age where they have no idea what
it is
and God forbid they make genuine you
know decisions that can impact them
later in life it seems crazy
it's because it's not enough anymore
it's not just gay people getting married
it's
hear the new standards men and women are
out
rewrite the biology textbook
can we watch the thing about getting the
spike
women's sports are going to be
completely dominated by trans men it's
like it's not enough now it's just it
used to be Live and Let Live it's no
longer that it's now this is in
intrusive into people in every space and
Athletics and education people are kind
of just going hey man I'm a little sick
of this
uh this Riley games uh girl tweeted
it was a dude I think it was a trans
woman who spikes a volleyball into this
woman's face
hold on let's see
now what is this tell us what this is so
here it is this is uh a woman's
volleyball game and then there is a
biological male competing as a or a
trans woman playing in this and so they
spike the ball really hard into this
woman's face and then this woman that
was spiked is then speaking in another
clip about how you know it's not fair
yeah okay let's watch it here's the
spike
[Music]
okay green yes
[Applause]
[Music]
this is just what's gonna happen by the
way look at the turnout for the
volleyball huh
this is what's gonna this is by the way
this is insane
this is completely insane right
a biological male has so many advantages
that and then just
you know it's just not this doesn't and
then they go well we don't want
ostracized transgender people from
Sports and you go you understand that
but it doesn't seem to be going the
other way it seems to be primarily
biological men dominating women
oh you know like that seems to be what
it is it's not like biological women are
getting into men's sports and like
[__] it up it seems to be moving one
way which might say something about
biology I don't know
let's watch it one more time I love the
after it and they're like oh
and what does this woman say afterwards
22 I was severely injured in a high
school volleyball game by a transgender
Athlete on the opposing team
I suffered from a concussion and neck
injury that to this day I'm still
recovering from
other injuries I still suffer from today
include impaired Vision partial
Paralysis on my right side constant
headaches as well as anxiety it seems
like she seems like she's been able to
play the rest of my I mean it was
impressive ball to the head I'm listen
I'm not I I'm saying that this is not
right I don't think that biological men
should be just dominating women's sports
she does seem like she's turning it up a
little bit should I suffer from a lot of
things from this
um but it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy
that this is where we're at now I mean
that is crazy to watch and in fighting
it's crazy to watch when you have
biological men just pummeling women in
the ring and I'm four hitting women in
your own home
but not in not in athletics not when it
counts not when there are Judges I'm
forwarding your own home
timberlandcomedy.com for any and all
live dates we have coming up we have uh
the Parks Casino in Philly in September
we are at Denver Comedy Works in July
and the win in Vegas in July baby
Hampton Beach Casino is gonna be up bro
there it is in Hampton uh Beach Casino
in New Hampshire August 19th so we do
have a few scattered dates throughout
the summer
uh come see me Las Vegas Colorado
Hampton Beach and then Parks Casino
September 8th and 9th shows in Philly we
always love them uh timberlandcomedy.com
you can get all your tickets there Tim J
Dillon on Instagram and Twitter where we
may start uploading the show big news is
coming some big guests some big
interviews that I'll be doing as well on
other platforms uh thank you again
patreon will be out later today and uh
we appreciate it and just go and spike
the ball go and spike the ball in the
face of that of that's what life's about
use your advantages spike the ball and
hit him in the face
good night such a bear